[Musique]
château on en sait un peu plus sur le
deal dont le tournage est en cours à
l'ancienne bibliothèque universitaire de
saint quentin en yvelines
à commencer par le casting jean françois
stévenin il fera une apparition
sont également présents jean claude
dreyfus figure emblématique de
delicatessen ou encore alison arngrim
alias nellie oleson dans la petite
maison dans la prairie
enfin en compte deux autres fidèles du
metteur en scène jackie berroyer et
dominique darty alors mon personnage est
un enquêteur qui s'appelle castan et qui
d'ailleurs que porte le même nom et le
même look que dans un autre film de mots
qui dans lequel j'ai tourné qui
s'appelle la bête la bête de miséricorde
mon personnage il est là dans la
continuité de ce que dans lesquelles
j'ai toujours joué les fantômes à celle
et belphégor les vidéos etc
puisque je les ai tous faits depuis
chaque canton je joue tous les
malfaisants tous les torts du tout les
touches heures du pcci tous les tarés
possibles et inimaginables
quant au scénario il serait inspiré de
celui de menaces sorti en 1939
une histoire de sans papiers dans une
français des années 30 hermétique aux
nouveaux et à l'inconnu
les premiers tours de manivelle à du
deal ont été donnés en début de semaine
et le film devrait être présenté en
ouverture du prochain festival du polar
dans la ville dans une dizaine de mois
mais au rythme où se tourner les scènes
entre réécriture du scénario et coup de
sang du réalisateur rien n'est moins sûr
il ya des aspects très divers chez mocky
alors trois caps eux les compliments
qu'on fait sur lui les reproches aux
ciseaux tout aussi fondées mais c'est un
ensemble il faut prendre le tout quoi
[Musique]